you've said that in Toronto as an
undergrad you did a senior thesis or
literature survey on artificial
intelligence this was 1964 correct what
was the AI landscape ideas dreams at
that time I think that was one of the
well you've heard of AI winters this is
whatever the opposite was AI summer or
something
there's one of these things where people
thought that boy we could do anything
with computers that all these hard
problems we could computers will solve
them they will do machine translation
they will play games like chess that
they will do Mitch you know prove
theorems in geometry there are all kinds
of examples like that where people
thought boy we could really do those
sorts of things
um and you know I read the kool-aid in
sometimes it's a wonderful collection of
papers called computers and thought that
was published and about that era and
people were very optimistic and then of
course it turned out that what people
thought was just a few years down the
pike was more than a few years down the
pike and some parts of that are more or
less now sort of under control i we
finally do play games like go and chess
and so on better than then people do but
there are others on machine translation
is a lot better than it used to be but
that's you know 50 close to 60 years of
progress and a lot of evolution in
hardware and a tremendous amount more
data upon which you can build systems
that actually can learn from some of
that and and the the infrastructure to
support developers working together like
an open source movement the Internet
period there's also an empowering but
what lesson do you draw from that the
opposite of winter that optimism well I
guess the lesson is that in the short
run it's pretty easy to be too
pessimistic or maybe too optimistic and
in the long run you probably shouldn't
be too pessimist I'm not saying that
very well it reminds me of this remark
from Arthur Clarke science fiction
authors says you know when some
distinguish but elderly person says that
something is him is possible he's
probably right and if he says it's
impossible he's almost surely wrong but
you don't know what the time scale is
that time scale is good all right so
what are your thoughts on this new
summer of AI now in the work with
machine learning in y'all networks
you've kind of mentioned you started to
try to explore and look into this world
that seems fundamentally different from
the world of heuristics and algorithms
like search that it's now purely sort of
trying to take huge amounts of data and
learn learn from that day to write
programs from the data yeah look I think
it's it's very interesting I am
incredibly far from an expert most of
what I know I've learned from my
students and they're probably
disappointed in how little I've learned
from them but um I think it has
tremendous potential for certain kinds
of things I mean games is one where it
obviously has had an effect on some of
the others as well
I think there's and this is speaking
from definitely not expertise I think
there are serious problems in certain
kinds of machine learning learning at
least because what they're learning from
is the data that we give them and if the
data we give them has something wrong
with it then what they learn from it is
probably wrong too and the obvious thing
is some kind of bias in the data that
the data has stuff in it like I don't
know women earned is good at men as men
at something okay that's just flat wrong
but if it's in the data because of
historical treatment then that machine
learning stuff will propagate that and
that is a serious worry the the positive
part of that is what machine learning
does is reveal the bias in the data and
puts a mirror to our own society and in
so doing helps us remove the bite you
know helps us work on ourselves it's a
mirror to ourselves
yeah that's an optimistic point of view
and if it works that way that would be
absolutely great and and what I don't
know is whether it does work that way or
whether the you know the AI mechanisms
or machine learning
mechanisms reinforce and amplify things
that have been wrong in the past and I
don't know I but I think that's a
serious thing that we have to be
concerned about let me ask you another
question okay
I know nobody knows but what do you
think it takes to build a system of
human level intelligence that's been the
dream from the 60s we talk about games
about language about about image
recognition but really the dream is to
create human level or superhuman level
intelligence what do you think it takes
to do that
and are we close I haven't a clue and I
don't know trying to trick you into a
hypothesis I mean Turing talked about
this in his paper on machine
intelligence back in G's or early 50s or
something like that and he had the idea
of the Turing test and I don't know
whether the Turing test is good I don't
know it's an interesting test at least
it's in some vague sense objective
whether you can read anything into the
conclusions is a different story
you